this is from E online it says Penny
polar bear is very excited to share
about her parents for the first time in
its nearly two decade long run Peppa Pig
has included a same-sex couple the
moment comes during the episode entitled
families which aired on Britain's
Channel 5 on September 6th the short
scene happens when Peppa's classmate
Penny polar bear discusses her family
during the school day uh I'm Penny polar
bear she says as she draws a photo of
her two mothers in a dress
I live with my mommy and my other mommy
one mommy is a doctor and one mommy
Cooks spaghetti I love spaghetti
so this is a
quite a lot of celebrating happening on
social media and in the media today as
uh Peppa Pig as as now
included a gay couple Another One Bites
the Dust
another one goes woke I can't say I'm
surprised by it I knew the day was going
to come it is a it is especially
upsetting for me because I have have
always found Peppa Pig to be one of the
least objectionable and by that I mean
least annoying kid shows uh most even
taking the wokeness out of it completely
most kid shows are totally obnoxious and
stupid and I I can't even be in the same
room as them Paw Patrol that sort of
thing and also the the animation is just
ugly and lifeless and and everything
about it is is terrible Peppa Pig I've
always found to be
you know
tolerable it's got a little bit of a
charm to it and there are there are
moments here and there a little bit of
Sly kind of humor for the adults and not
much of that but a little bit but mostly
it's just it's it's a it's a seemingly
nice kind of innocent show for kids
and I can and I can be in the room while
it's on without wanting to jump out of a
window
but of course I knew that eventually
this would happen it can't you know
anything that exists for kids any kind
of kid entertainment kid content
eventually they'll get around to it and
now they have a Peppa Pig let me ask you
something what if there was someone out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day I
think that would be pretty creepy we can
all agree well what if I told you that's
exactly what happens every time you go
online your internet provider like at T
or comcast whoever it is allowed to
store logs of every website you've ever
visited and then they can legally sell
that data to anyone they want that's why
I always use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure server so your
internet provider can't see or log what
you do online now if you're wondering if
there's a maybe a catch here that well
if they're routing my my data does that
mean that they can log my data and
you're right to think that because many
vpns claim to have a no logs policy but
have been caught logging customer
activity anyway expressvpn does not do
that though they have uh trusted server
technology and what that means is that
you can stop letting people keep logs of
what you do online by visiting Express
addressvpn.com Matt walshow right now
and find out how you can get three
months free now there are two moves
that the left always pulls with these
sorts of things very familiar and
they're already pulling these moves here
in this case where they say to any
critics like anyone like myself who
criticizes the inclusion of a you know
gay subplot on Peppa Peppa Pig
what they'll say to us is number one why
do you care so much why do you care why
do you make such a big deal out of it
and then the other thing they'll say is
that this isn't political is this
There's No Agenda here it's just it's
just uh you know they're just showing
that gay people exist
well neither of those narratives are
going to hold in this case because of
this continuing with the E online story
says the inclusive storyline has been a
long time coming in 2019 a petition
called for the show to feature same-sex
couples so children at quote an
impressionable age can be educated on
them
right because this is what you want when
you have your
four-year-old watching Peppa Pig you
want them you want her to be educated on
same-sex couples
rather than being educated on you know
one two three ABC that sort of thing
oh you want them to be educated about
sexuality says the petition
it went on the petition did excluding
same-sex families will teach children
that only families with either a single
parent or two parents of different Sexes
are normal this means that children of
same-sex parents may feel alienated by
Peppa Pig and that other children may be
more likely to bully them simply through
ignorance
well except that first of all
single-parent households and same you
know different sex two parent households
are the normal
those are the normal households just
like statistically it's just a fact that
those are the normal Arrangements
in our society and in fact in the whole
history of human civilization that's a
that's a statistical reality
but
the fact that there was a petition
okay so you're petitioning and there was
I think there's like 30 000 plus
signatures on this
of people on the left petitioning for
lesbian characters in Peppa Pig
the fact that there's a petition means
that no you you can't you can't hit us
with the why do you care so much you
obviously care quite a bit you
petitioned for it you care so much about
the sexuality of cartoon characters in
preschooler shows that you you had a
petition for it
and we also know that the characters are
not being included just because that's
the story that the that the people who
make the show want to tell they're doing
it in response to a political petition
so
if you're on the left you obviously care
about this and it is a it is a political
ideological move
that's an absolute fact
given that it arises as a result of a
petition
and now you know the parents just have
to decide do you want your kids watching
shows that are you know where the plots
are created based on left-wing petitions
the answer for me is certainly no
and we're rapidly getting to the point
where there are just no shows at all
that my kids can watch and maybe that's
not such a bad thing because there are
other things to do than watch TV well if
you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the Subscribe button and ring the bell
to get more content like it if you're
craving more content go watch or listen
to my full show at dailywire.com Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast